foreign
for what it's worth I think you would
make an incredible brunette
Ron Swanson
that you had two Ex-Wives named Tammy so
I was hoping that there was one that you
got along with and no I hate them both
on my death bed my final wish is to have
my Ex-Wives rush to my side so I can use
my dying breath to tell them both to go
to hell one last time
would I get married again oh absolutely
if you don't believe in love what's the
point of living
you've aged horribly
you
son of a oh my God what is your
problem nothing
excuse me I did okay
we're fine we're fine please
when you meddle in someone's personal
life it's just so rewarding
oh yeah
oh yeah got it the usual place
[Laughter]
[Music]
good morning Jerry that is a beautiful
sweater vest April
you look like you could use twenty
dollars am I right why because you're a
kid and kids always need money I need
money Ah that's why you're my favorite
Tom when Tiger Woods feels Invincible he
wears a red shirt and black pants Good
morning Deputy Ron wears the same thing
after he's had sex I'm a simple man
I like pretty dark-haired women and
breakfast food but this stock photo I
bought at a framing store isn't real
today I got the real thing
a naked Tammy made me breakfast this
morning
I should have taken a picture of it
Diane is awesome and she likes you and
you like her I can tell hey I don't
recall inviting you in here and B I did
not like her she's not my type her life
is messy messy is fun okay my whole life
is a giant mess and I love it I mean
look at my hair I have gum in my hair
listen I will not pursue Diane end of
story
excellent work everyone particularly you
Ron you have one very satisfied citizen
what did you do for her fixed her
pothole is that a euphemism no then
great work in fact she's out in the
hallway and wants to thank you herself
if you're here to complain about the
pothole I guarantee I did it correctly
actually I'm here to ask you out for
dinner
for dinner really well I hope you're not
the kind of man who needs to ask the
lady out I'm a middle school vice
principal I don't screw around does that
freak you out
no on the contrary
so dinner
please and thank you
it'll be casual made to wear makeup
I begrudgingly admit that the 3-1-1
program is a moderate success
I'm still not sure why the citizen
decided to come speak with me in person
but I'm just happy to see a government
program finally work
call off the dogs you and I both know
that in my entire adult life I have
never checked a book out of the library
oh my God she's amazing
oh
I admit there was a time when that sort
of behavior would have driven me wild
but I am in a healthy relationship now
Tamara a relationship with him a lovely
intelligent self-possessed pediatric
surgeon named Wendy sounds like a real
strippers do nothing for me I like
a strong salt of the earth
self-possessed woman at the top of her
field your stuffy grafts your Cheryl
swoopses
but I will take a free breakfast buffet
Anytime Anyplace
she just knows you so well and I was
starting to wonder if I was ever going
to get to that point
I'm worried that maybe there isn't room
in your life for another woman
at this very moment Leslie is throwing
herself in front of a freight train
named Tammy for me and you Leslie is a
wonderful loyal friend who's very
important in my life but I would sooner
visit Europe
then I have something romantic happen
between us
although if you would like to visit
Europe
I like you so much I'd be willing to
risk it
but not France right now
see you know me pretty well already but
you're about to get to know me even
better I brought you here because I want
to show you something
that almost no one knows about certainly
not Tammy and not even Leslie knob
ladies and gentlemen and especially the
ladies
put your hands together for the one the
only my man Mr Duke silver
hey
a mighty fine holiday evening to you all
it might be cold outside
but it's about to get warm all up in my
jazz
I of course am Duke silver
and I would like to dedicate this first
song
to my Duchess
[Music]
Hello darling what a surprise hey
we talk maybe in private
oh
you and me I believe she's referring to
me son please excuse us
so I
am pregnant
I see I don't understand how we were so
careful I warned you about this standard
birth control methods aren't usually
effective against a Swanson I got about
a million thoughts running around my
head but I really just want to know what
you're thinking
okay here's what I'm thinking
I was going to wait until our
anniversary take you somewhere romantic
perhaps in a canoe most likely in a
canoe
I actually built a canoe for that
purpose but given the news and given my
significant
feelings for you
now seems as good a time as any
Ron Swanson
Diane Lewis
will you marry me
yes
on one condition anything my love ask me
for anything in the world and I'll give
it to you except a destination wedding
just the opposite
we'd both been married before I don't
want anything big or elaborate in fact
the smaller the better I assume you can
deal with that are you kidding as far as
I'm concerned we could go up to the
fourth floor right now
there's nothing I love more than
squeegeeing slime off a highway
underpass where are you guys going the
fourth floor getting married okey-dokey
well catch you later
what
are you dead you look like you're
enrictus I just I'm having so many
thoughts and feelings that I'm
ice right now would you ladies like to
come can I be the best man why not let's
go Ron is getting married and I love him
and and I care about him and this is
[Music]
the good arrange balloons or a flower
cake or a bouncy castle ah Ethel beavers
we would like a marriage license please
and thank you what's the date of the
wedding today it's a bit unusual but we
don't care
Leslie Knope would you please be my
matron of honor Diane
you have no idea
what that means to me she gets it let's
go well
it is like a waking nightmare
nightmare rice I need to find some rice
I need to throw some rice why is there
no rice in this municipal government
building I found a Justice guy these are
the marrying people this is Carl hello
Carl my fiance and I would like to get
married right now right here haven't I
done a quickie wedding for you before
it's certainly possible but this one's
going to stick I need your full names
for the license Ronald Ulysses Swanson
Diane Tammy Lewis Tammy your middle name
kidding it's Elizabeth
let's go Carl hey let's pump the brakes
Carl okay belay that order Carl shortest
possible ceremony I'm tired of not being
married to this woman do you Ron Swanson
to be your wife certainly do
you Diane
yes okay Power vested in me before you
Carl just one second I would just like
to give a short speech if I may you have
10 seconds
at first glance it may seem as though
Ron Swanson and I have nothing in common
but Webster's Dictionary defines friend
thank you Leslie I could tell where you
were going with that it was going to be
beautiful I Now Pronounce You man and
wife
great job everyone the reception will be
held in each of our individual houses
alone Pretend This is rice